my friend darius dale how are you
i'm uh i'm good man i'm good personally
but i'm concerned about these markets
here dude am i gonna lie to you
yesterday the federal reserve 75 basis
point hike after they leaked it i went
to the wall street journal and leaked it
uh what's your thought position
yeah is it is it a leak if you go
directly to the most widely watched
source and tell them very specifically
no i'm not sure but uh say hey i want to
tell you something but don't tell them
that i told you but just write the
article
yeah
exactly by the way why are you wearing a
suit
i'm glad that you asked my friend uh
we're in a bear market and this exact
suit and this exact tie defeated the
2018 bear market i'll be wearing this
suit and tie every day until we defeat
the 2022 bear market i love that look at
that scruff man yeah oh my god we're
getting old yeah hey listen it got a
little less hair but still got the same
suit and tie that's all that matters
absolutely
all right so what's going on with the
federal reserve what how do you read
into their 75 basis point hike rather
than the 50 basis points they had been
saying previously
i can't answer that question by the way
put that clip back on with you and stork
it
look like you would absolutely steamroll
him dude look at the size difference
that's that's linebacker versus punter
right there listen uh this is where they
were asking me in 2018 like hey what do
you think the price is down like 80 now
that we're buying all the way down
oh i love that hell yeah man well good
so uh yeah let's get into the fed
yesterday so uh overarching takeaway is
that
this is the most hawkish fed meeting
we've seen since 1994. um we will be
talking about this 25 30 years down the
road because it's really the first time
really since then
uh that the fed has effectively
confirmed that they're comfortable with
sending the economy into recession to
defeat inflation you can make the case
that they weren't even as hawkish back
then because greenspan was sort of uh
mom's the word generally speaking with
respect to forward guidance that's more
of a bernanke yell and pow fed uh
dynamic so you could also make the case
that this was probably the most hawkish
fed meeting since going back to paul
volcker
in the early 80s um and it's very clear
from my perspective that there's going
to be a significant reduction in
liquidity from financial markets over
the medium term
until the fed sees the whites of the
eyes of inflation's back breaking
completely
when you start to think about uh
their current positioning do they
believe what they're saying and i want
to uh give you a very specific example
they claim that they are taking this
aggressive stance some may say that they
are trying to uh posture kind of in a
poll volcker uh we're serious about
taming inflation we're going to raise
interest rates but then on their own
projections they believe inflation's
still gonna be over five percent at the
end of the year
they don't think that it'll even be sub
three percent by the end of next year
why are they saying they're being so
aggressive but still telling us hey six
months from now you're still going to
have five plus percent inflation which
will be compounded on top of seven
percent inflation in december of 2021.
yes because uh let's not forget that
this is a fed who
i think deep down at its core believes
that inflation is still somewhat
transitory at least that there are
transitory components uh to the
inflation that we're observing uh
obviously if you think about food and
energy prices you know roughly ten
percent on a three month annualized
basis for or sorry twelve percent on
three months analyze basis for food
fifty percent on a three-month
annualized basis for energy the fed is
is
convinced and always will be convinced
that that kind of inflation is you know
generally speaking transitory because
it's not sticky however as we talked
about on this program and haven't talked
about this program for six nine months
now that there are sticky components of
inflation particularly when you look at
something like the atlanta fed sticky
cpi you know roughly seven percent on a
three-month annualized basis fastest
since the early 90s and then median cpi
6.4 percent uh fastest on a three-month
analyst basis fastest rates ever you
know there are parts of inflation that
are very sticky and and you know one
thing i think we have to remember as
investors because again everyone talking
about inflation right now you know lisa
from an investment perspective you know
has not lived through a serious
inflation shock before you have to go
away back to the 70s and early 80s to
get to
to that time to that part of the time
series and so the reality is inflation's
a sticky disease it gets worse unless
it's getting better and what he's
effectively saying is we're willing to
do more and more and more to get it to
go get better but it's not going to get
better overnight because again there are
some very sticky components to it that
are already kind of in the pipeline so
when you think about this we've seen
asset prices falling will they uh
wave the white flag if asset prices fall
enough or do they just not care at all
whatever happens to those asset prices
oh no they care because ultimately there
is a legitimate feedback and response
mechanism between asset park markets and
our economy so there's a couple
statistics i'll throw you to support
that um us economy you know while we're
down from a consumer balance perspective
in terms of overall debt private
non-financial sector debt has actually
risen in the last sort of 10 to 15 years
not as quite as high as it was prior to
the financial crisis but it's still
pretty elevated at about 160 of gdp and
the reason that matters is because we
also have a very financialized economy
when you look at private non-financial
sector debt in terms of the percent that
is warehoused on bank balance sheet that
isn't you know turning over it's you
know going to be sitting there to
maturity versus that's about 30
versus the amount of private sector
non-financial sector debt um that is
sort of warehoused by non-bank
participants shadow banks hedge funds
asset managers etc that at 70 percent it
tells you that what happens in the
markets will have a material impact on
the debt dynamics of the economy not
just issuing new debt but also rolling
over existing debt and that is an issue
in terms of uh you know uh
that will cause you know the significant
tightening of natural conditions will
cause and have a material adverse impact
on the growth cycle which ultimately
feed back into the inflation cycle by
reducing demand so this is what the fed
wants they just don't want too much of
it but yesterday we learned that it's
for the first time that this is a
federal reserve that actually wants that
outcome and so that that's uh that's a
pretty significant move when you look at
things i think this morning u.s housing
starts uh the forecast was minus 1.8 if
i remember correctly and it ended up
coming in at like minus 14.4 percent
just like something so egregiously off
from the forecast
do you expect us to see more and more uh
inaccuracies in forecasts because now
we're getting into a kind of uncharted
water we're getting into period of uh so
much complexity in the global macro
environment that's moving that it's
going to be very difficult for many of
these economists and forecasters to
actually be accurate
yeah so there's two things i would say
about that the first is
we should expect more very uh more
significant downside surprises to
housing data over the medium term uh
just going back to what i just talked
about in terms of how financialized the
economy is obviously the housing sector
is one of the most financialized
components of the economy and we're
currently undergoing the biggest shock
and mortgage rates at least as far back
as we can get the data since going back
to the late 90s
ever it's bigger than the shock we
experienced in o6 ahead of the global
financial crisis ahead of the housing
bust and downturn uh it's bigger than
the shock we experienced in 2013 it's
bigger than the shock we experienced in
2018. we're talking about a 3.2 uh sigma
move 3.2 z score on a trailing
three-year basis in terms of the move
we've seen in mortgage rates from
basically three percent all the way up
to six percent so that's going to cause
a significant slowdown in housing market
activity the number two point i want to
make in response to your question i
think
you know there is legitimate risk that
we could be in recession right now i
mean if you look at the q1 gdp report
and again now most of the the negative
move in the q1 gdp report was
as a function of inventories real final
sales were very robust in the first
quarter but again we had a negative
overall headline gdp print and you look
at something like the atlanta feds uh
now cast for the second quarter we're
basically at zero when it could
obviously get worse you know once we get
the updated forecast after we got the uh
rancid uh retail sales data and
obviously housing data today we could be
currently sitting here in the second
consecutive quarter of negative headline
gdp and typically what happens when
you're in recession is that the
revisions to economic statistics tend to
be very very aggressive um they tend to
be much much larger than your
traditional revisions on a
month-to-month quarter to quarter basis
and so
again i don't want to make a headline
say i think where the economy's in in
recession because again real final sales
are still trending quite positively but
certainly if we are in recession um
you're definitely going to see some
significant revisions and your
significant downside surprises in a lot
of the reporting of economic statistics
can you talk a little bit about the
disconnect maybe between the official
metrics and then uh how people on the
ground actually could be experiencing
recessionary uh like effects where it's
wage growth it's increasing cost they're
you know slowing down investment there's
less hiring going on like how do we
actually decipher what's happening in
the quote-unquote real economy versus
hey did we actually get the true
definition of a recession uh in the
metrics
yeah so uh let me start that let me
answer that in reverse great question
but you're always on fire with the
questions
the in reverse
you know i think it is important to find
what a recession is right there's
different definitions of recession
there's a technical recession which is
two consecutive quarters of negative gdp
uh from an intent for uh there's also
the sort of more qualitative definition
of recession which is a significant pull
back in animal spirits uh you know
particularly uh from the corporate
sector where corporates you know are
laying off uh laying off workers and and
really doing what they can to sort of um
to sort of protect profits um and that
usually has a significant uh adverse
outcome on on growth statistics and then
there's a third uh also qualitative uh
explanation uh that's part of the nber
which is the uh the official body who
dates recessions in the us there's a
third qualitative definition which is a
significant downside deviation from
trend and overall output and a
significant downside deviation from
trend and overall employment so
obviously those two qualitative
definitions kind of line up with each
other i tend to sit more on the
qualitative camp who gives a damn about
two consecutive quarters of negative gdp
that you know those can be gained from
an accounting standpoint what really
matters is how far and how quickly you
deviate from the trend in output and
employment and so in terms of uh walking
you through how that might look like on
the ground i think the first thing that
matters is
there's been a significant reduction in
in consumer confidence particularly when
you look at the university of michigan
survey we're obviously a below trend
from a conference board survey as well
but when you marry that up to the
significant reduction that we've seen in
in in ceo confidence as well you know
we're now we're sort of in the pro phase
pro the point of the process where there
is a crisis of confidence that it's very
much being observed and that crisis of
confidence uh this let's take the crypto
uh sector uh as an example that crisis
of confidence can filter the economy in
a lot of different ways right like let's
say the you know price of bitcoin stays
down here around 20 000 or goes even
south of 20 000 what you're going to
start to see is more layoffs at places
like coinbase etc you're going to see
less advertising spin by companies like
ftx and coinbase etc and you're going to
have matt damon flying to vegas you know
less frequently and then the hotels in
vegas where he's spending money at the
casino are going to you know start the
layoff staff and workers and this is how
it works and now you magnify that and
multiply that across the economy that's
how you get a recession what typically
happens in a growth slide is that
there's one two maybe a few connected
sectors that are all sort of you know
experiencing real negative dynamics a
recession is when you're seeing that
broad based across the economy across
multiple sectors
yeah we've got this uh tweet uh that
zero hedge put out that said the last
and only time the s p was down 10 of 11
weeks
nixon was about to end the gold standard
and killed bretton woods to quote fix
the us inflation problem and we've got
the the chart that shows 10 out of 11
weeks for the s p to be down we then get
coming off of the gold standard how
severe
do you think that the solution is going
to be here is it simply something where
they can use their current tools of
interest rates and quantitative
tightening and get this under control or
will we see some kind of very very
severe action to try to get inflation
under control
uh well it depends if inflation
continues surprising to the upside in
the way that it did
last friday in the may cbi report which
we obviously we presage very well in
this program and other programs then
yeah they're going to get incrementally
draconian because what to me and again i
think this is qualitative and you have
to make a market call
generally speaking i make calls to make
money in financial markets when i hear
powell talk about inflation particularly
when i hear him talk about how inflation
impacts low-income families i'm telling
you i've been doing this
boring ass job for 13 and a half years
and i've never once heard any central
banker from any place around the world
with the exception of raglan rajan over
at the reserve bank in india talk about
the impact of inflation on low-income
consumers to me it seems like powell
understands just how damning and how
recessionary the conditions already feel
like for the lower income cohorts of our
society and so to me i think this sort
of you know their willingness to do
whatever it takes from a financial
tightening standpoint and from a growth
reduction and growth standpoint to get
to a situation where inflation's much
lower and the economy is in a much more
stable footing i think their willingness
to do that is much higher than i think
the average market participant believes
and we've thought that all year
when you think about something like
yield curve controls we were talking
yesterday to uh nick carter and he
thinks that that's on our horizon how do
you view that and do you think that's
something that we should expect
your curve control would be on the
horizon
if inflation
became runaway and the only reason i
think yield curve control would be on
the horizon if inflation became runaway
is if the fed allowed it to become
runaway right the fed the fed is
ultimately responsible at least from a
monetary standpoint and just given how
financialized the economy is is
ultimately responsible for doing
something about inflation and they can
do a significant amount about inflation
right let's let's go back and you know
one thing that the fed uh i i saw a lot
of investors are chastising the fed
about at least a lot of investors have
similar market views that i do
they haven't talked at all about the
ridiculous amount of fiscal stimulus we
dumped into the economy not just
domestically but globally throughout the
pandemic and they also haven't talked at
all about the sort of aggressive
monetary easing that we saw even despite
we you know even despite the
inflationary pressure that was building
from a from a uh you know sort of a
supply and demand perspective in terms
of overly stimulating aggregate demand
at a time where it was very clear that
we were seeing a concomitant reduction
in labor supply and ultimately a
reduction in energy and agricultural
supply as well and obviously the
geopolitical impacts from russia ukraine
are only making those last two dynamics
worse and so ultimately the fed can do
something about inflation it looks like
they want to do something about
inflation but if they chose not to do
something about inflation and let
inflation hang out at these very
aggressive levels or even get worse over
the medium to long term then they will
have to do yield curve control but i
don't think that's where we're headed
because ultimately i think the fed um at
least now for now seems like it has to
resolve to get this the job done so
nick's point i think was uh hey they
just can't increase interest rates above
some threshold whether that's five
percent six percent whatever they'll
bankrupt the united states and
historically okay so explain that's what
i wanted to get to explain how high you
think they could hike rates if needed
so let's not forget that the one the
federal reserve uh has a it's a limited
balance sheet but it's also not just the
federal reserve right there is also this
thing called regulation right we could
trap a lot of money in our in our
ecosystem by changing the rules of the
game in terms of how banks are allowed
to operate both internationally and
domestically you know how we're allowed
to sort of transact from a across
capital uh across border perspective
from in the from the perceptive capital
markets they can do a lot of moving with
dials and levers to effectively crowd
money into
the treasury market which is what they
did going back to the regulations we saw
in uh in 2008 2009 and then ultimately
the regulations changed as we saw in
2015 2016. so they have levers that they
can pull without having to resort to
something that looks like yield curve
control um you know from the perspective
of the central bank but again i think
you know to nick you know i'm not saying
nick's wrong example we don't know
anything about the future no one does
but my point is i i think we're a long
way away from even having to get there
because ultimately they can they can
there's ways in which they can they get
uh trap money into the into the u.s
treasury market so the u.s is not going
to default anytime soon is at the top of
the global capital structure if the u.s
defaults it means that you me every
business every company every country in
the world likely would have defaulted
first
when you think about uh places with very
high degrees of inflation uh take
argentina others uh they start to put
price controls in place and we've
obviously seen uh a recent letter that
was sent to a bunch of the oil companies
saying basically you're greedy stop
raising prices we saw the white house
communications director recently say you
know be a patriot keep your prices low
um
what's going on and like should we
expect price controls in the united
states at some point in the future
so so how stupid is that right like you
run a business i run a business
be a patriot keep prices low well it
costs money more money to run the
business i gotta either pass on the cost
to the ultimate consumer of the the good
or service that we're selling or i have
to have less profits or even negative
profits who you're going to
disincentivize people from
running businesses and producing
incremental goods and supply of goods
and services which is what we need
if you start instituting price controls
and we talked about this last week price
control is a short-term you know uh
reward and from from a amelioration of
price change perspective but they're
guaranteed to give you higher inflation
in the future because all you're doing
is reducing the total amount of
available supply on a lag right and so
clearly the the what's causing inflation
what has caused every inflation in the
history of inflation since going back to
adam and eve and maybe even before that
if you guys watch uh ancient
civilizations on amazon which is great
by the way
it's always a mismanagement of supply or
misalignment of supply and demand you
cannot have an inflation without a
misalignment of supply and demand one or
two of those curves have to shift in an
adverse manner to have a sustained
inflation and that's clearly what we
have right now so one of the things uh
along that same line is the national
average gas price according to uh
aaa is now five dollars uh it's over
five dollars uh we've seen gas prices in
california get as high as eight nine ten
dollars in certain places um
should we expect food prices to explode
upwards even further if all of a sudden
oil and natural gas prices are going up
like is there a connectedness between uh
food and uh and energy prices
yes that is correct so uh great question
as well so uh historically speaking you
know what you typically have is one
whenever energy prices are going up it's
a it's a it's a
intermediate good for pretty much every
other good in the world it's hard to
generate goods without you know energy
energy as an input um and obviously
petrochemicals et cetera for plastics et
cetera um but there's also energy you
know is it part of the price for stuff
like nitrogen which is obviously used um
to you know to produce agricultural
goods and so when you think about you
know this nitrogen fertilizer we have
the ongoing uh trending rise in energy
prices those two factors alone are
likely to continue to keep upward
pressure on food prices at least until
we find some amelioration there um and
this is why historically when you go
back and you look at recessions
a lot of times you know more than 50 of
the time the price of energy crude oil
tends to peak in the actual recession
like and we talked about it this couple
weeks ago you actually it usually just
goes higher and higher and higher and
higher until it ultimately destroys
demand for itself which is usually the
last thing like the last category of
goods that we consume where demand gets
destroyed right you can't not go to work
you can't not eat and so ultimately the
price will rise up until the point where
uh supply and demand are in balance and
ultimately that that is um you know
that's one of those factors that causes
a recession how do you think about
compounding increases in prices so i
mentioned you know last december the
number was seven percent inflation they
were still conducting asset purchases at
the time uh and this december they think
that it'll be at five percent so let's
just say those numbers are right we now
are getting into kind of multiple years
of high year-over-year growth but that's
not just of the cpi number obviously
there's things that make up cpi in terms
of whether that's gasoline food at home
out of the home whatever like how do
what's like a rule of thumb or a
framework to analyze now when we get
into these compounding and introduces
things like base effect uh to have
people understand what exactly is
happening to the price of goods
yeah so there's uh this there's a few
ways you can get around that just
statistically from a mathematical
perspective so um if you want to
understand sort of
how inflation's compounded over the last
you know two years or three years you
can look at what we call invite wall
street something like a two-year stack
which is just the two-year average uh
growth or inflation rate you know in
that particular period um you know it's
you know q1 or you know let's call it
the last month et cetera or um you could
also do it on it from an index
perspective right like you can say hey
look since the end of 2019 we're going
to index the inflation index you know
the the nominal the raw inflation index
relative to let's say something like we
all you know the the overall household
income or disposable personal income and
then you could see what the cumulative
change is over a period of over a longer
period of time you know those you know
if you do that you know for a long
period of time in the pandemic you saw
actually an increase uh in in in
in private sector uh disposable personal
income relative to the index change in
inflation we are now very clearly cost
crossing that chasm in the wrong
direction from the perspective of
consumer income and consumer balance
sheets so now inflation from a
cumulative perspective is really now
starting to take its toll uh on on
society and particularly on the lower
income courts society who can't you know
can't make easy substitutions for their
consumption goods and services or more
importantly just don't have this the
size of the wallet to absorb incremental
consumption
when you start to think about um
jobs
we're near
historic low unemployment we were at i
think 3.5 3.4 percent in uh february of
2020. obviously that skyrocketed 6.6
million people a week we're filing for
first time unemployment claims uh sort
of the pandemic it's come back down
we're at like 3.5 percent now uh but
when you go on twitter when you read
headlines on these news organizations it
seems like there's lots of layoffs that
have already occurred and more people
are
thinking that they could be coming
should we expect unemployment to
aggressively grow in america
yeah unemployment's not going to
aggressively grow until we slow
economically aggressively now
our models are have been are calling for
and have been calling for an aggressive
slow down economically starting this
summer time and persisting throughout
the fall and into the early part of next
year so um by the end of that process
yes we will start to see a rise in
unemployment and a reduction in overall
uh
you know in total employment but it's
hard you know employment itself is a
lagging indicator it lags the broader
rate of change cycle for growth and so
you typically need to observe that that
growth slowdown what you're observing
from a headline perspective it's just
sort of uh what you know we call from a
behavioral economic standpoint which is
just that's prospect theory you know we
anchor on negative news uh because
historically you know
our interpretation of negative news
feels worse than our interpretation of
positive news feels good and so it's
very easy to to get anchored on you know
when markets are having down days the
red on the screen it's you know stories
about layoffs etc um but the reality is
the u.s labor market added 390 000 jobs
on a net basis in the most recent data
point the most recent month which is may
you know that 390 000 jobs compares to
an average of 190 jobs month over month
you know in the five years ending in
2019 so we're basically running at about
a double in terms of the pace of total
employment growth which is not something
you're seeing on your screens every day
you're seeing obviously the layoffs
because you know those might be leading
indicators for the cycle getting worse
but ultimately i think what's likely to
happen is that we have a cooling of
labor market conditions and then
eventually an actual outright
deterioration if the fed has to continue
stepping its foot on the brake got it
and so when you start to think about uh
the best case scenario uh for asset
prices through the rest of this year is
your expectation that we go sideways to
down and we continue with kind of
aggressive fed policies uh or do you see
some relief and potentially uh could
could stocks end the year up uh or
anything like that
so uh it's a couple things i'll start by
saying
the most bullish scenario is having
recession now that kills inflation that
allows the fed to get off this path
the worst scenario is the longer
inflation stays hot the more likely it
is the fed has to keep stay on on this
path of a very aggressive monetary
tightening which will keep you know a
you know pressure on asset prices to con
you know risk assets bitcoin etc to
continue going lower in price um you
picked the hell of a day to wear that
suit by the way because tomorrow is a
op-ex friday um and our friends at spot
gamma
at brinkachuba who runs that fir that
service he's calling out that this is
the chunkiest op x in terms of the size
of overall puts that are likely to
expire since march of 2020. when you go
back to march 2020 that marked a very
significant low in in risk assets you
know multi-year low in risk assets um in
terms of removing all that exposure from
the uh from the short side of the trade
and causing dealers to unwind those bets
now what's obviously very different now
is in march of 2020 you had the fed
basically get as aggressive to the
easing side of the equation as they had
ever done basically doubled its balance
sheet overnight and kept it going with
120 billion qe for you know for
obviously way too long if you're talking
about today's inflation that is not the
macro setup today we are not at the
bottom of the growth cycle we're very
clearly not at the bottom of the
liquidity cycle so i'm concerned that
you might get a temporary bounce in risk
assets associated with that opex um you
know that opex um unwind uh that
ultimately is to be faded um you know
you know let's call it in a few weeks or
so and then one thing um you know
finally before we even in
i'm gonna be doing a boot camp uh with
my friend imran locke who runs options
insight if you want to understand some
of these options markets dynamics a
little bit better because again i think
this is going to be a very important one
as i just mentioned you want to
understand these op-ex dynamics options
market dynamics and ultimately how to
use options to hedge your portfolio um
we're going to come join us for this
boot camp we're going to be doing it on
july 7th through 9th again it's imran
lockover at optionsinsight.com
uh so go check that out if that's
something that's interesting because i
think it'll be very interesting over the
next month or two
my last question for you my friend
75 basis point hike in june they were
supposed to do 50 in june 50 in july uh
many people think that they have to
remain aggressive but jay powell
yesterday talked about 75 basis points
won't be common
what happens in july fifty seventy five
a hundred twenty five
does he think if inflation behaves it's
gonna be 50 right um but if inflation
stays doing you know some version of
what it's been doing which is trending
higher on a three-month annualized basis
it's going to be 75s and more qt
quantitative tightening until until the
eyes can see again this all boils down
to
how willing is the central bank you know
to to basically do something about
inflation and how quickly do they want
to do it and from my perspective again
this is just my own interpretation based
on you know analyzing not even analyzing
studying everything that these people
say and have been saying throughout this
entire process from my perspective it
seems like they're they're very
concerned that they don't want to lose
credibility of the fed and because once
you lose the credibility of the fed the
inflation genie or disease as i like to
call it is very much harder to treat and
ultimately don't forget that jay powell
is a human being do you really want to
retire as the guy who let the inflation
genie out of the bottle in the united
states of america and abroad no i think
he's trying to protect his legacy and
he's and he's comfortable with having a
mild to severe recession to doing that
this is if we got a recession we don't
have the debt dynamics in this economy
from a private non-financial sector
leverage perspective in terms of the
build up or the change in the debt
service ratio that would cause something
like the global financial crisis it'll
be a it'll be a sort of short-lived
recession that we can recover from and
get to better times and so i think
that's ultimately the bet they're
willing to make if you put a gun to
their head if they have to pick you know
mild to you know recession over a
continuation of inflation they're going
to pick mod recession for sure where can
we send people to find you on the
internet
absolutely man i appreciate that uh at
42 macro come check out our website come
check out our research uh produce uh you
know what i think is some of the world's
best research for for every investor and
everyone gets all the same research that
that tends to be an issue on wall street
um and then so and then if you can't
afford it um the 42 macro detail is my
twitter handle i appreciate everyone for
having me on and thank you catch air
next week
my friend you are doing a a fantastic
job thanks for keeping me educated i
dropped the link in the chat there
anyone who wants to go check out 42
macro highly
let's keep praying let's see what
happens
well i i'll say this prayer is not a
risk management strategy 42 macro is a
risk management
what a softball all right see you buddy
double salute
i'll see you guys later
cheers